foreign
I am literally crying
I'm just so freaking funny
oh boy I haven't cried from laughter in
a long time what is going on there
citizen my God my hair is still so wet
it is wet hair today what is going on
there I could have just waited like
another 15-20 minutes but we'll go with
the wet piece I was just in the mood for
a comedy you know uh and I was just like
like what's on my list that is a comedy
and this one stood out to me I remember
the trailer sort of and I remember being
like ah it looks funny and I just never
watched it so I was like all right yeah
let's let's do this one I hear it's kind
of an underrated film 17 Again made sure
to wear my French shirt because of Sir
Matthew Perry yeah go ahead leave a like
I would really appreciate that also
subscribe click that notification Bell
because we got other movie reactions
that we've been doing it for the Chanel
full-length Reaction watch alongs I'm
acting like this is the first time I've
ever said this information but you might
be damn full-length reaction watching
long story sync up with your own copy of
17 again I'm gonna watch this on Netflix
actually uh available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page and over
there we cover a bunch of shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch along is included but you could
also find the rest of the watch alongs
over there let's see what all the hype
is about
[Music]
class of 84.
[Music]
Zac Efron's so much more buff now when
he was already in shape really good
shape he looks so skinny compared to
today I'm just warming up coach just
talked to the Scout again he's coming at
night he's prepared to offer you a full
scholarship Jim Gaffigan is so funny I'm
glad you're here scar this whole Scout
thing is me wicked nervous
[Music]
oh my God is she pregnant
[Music]
oh no
[Applause]
[Music]
this is so much heavier already than I
expected
[Music]
she is preggers
wow
[Music]
Mike what are you doing Julie we're in
this together oh this is so sweet dang
that's your future
and told me this is gonna be so touching
it's only like two minutes in
hey I'm a sucker for that kind of [ __ ]
man
that's really sweet
[Music]
you know not that Matthew Perry is a bad
looking guy
because he's not but to go from Zac
Efron into Matthew Perry
you're looking at Scarlett kicking you
out of the house and the kids want
nothing to do with you as a negative
when in fact
I guess it's mostly negative
you're getting that big promotion today
right yes yes I am
today everything turns around for me see
knock them dead that Thor in the
background I feel like this movie was a
good choice the way corporate wants us
to spin it is that maybe in certain
situations a four-hour erection isn't
such a terrible thing
laughs
so congratulations Mike
yeah Mike if you could just slide to
your left so I can congratulate our new
RSM Wendy
you just slide here
[Music]
Mike O'Donnell sooner or later you all
come back to the old school
stand there and look at the picture of
the Glory Days
wonder what might have been
well of course I want to live in the
past
it was better there
I'll bet you wish you had it to do all
over again
is he gonna Grant this wish
basketball season's coming up you ready
yeah remember it's not how big you are
how big you play right up here
is that the theme of the movie
kid actors like Sterling something or
another isn't he
destroying our yard it's not our yard
it's my yard I'm gonna turn it into a
showpiece for my clients clients of what
landscape design the way I remember that
is that you spent about an hour working
on it and then you spent the next two
days complaining about if you had gone
to college then you could have hired
someone else to do it oh man
look try to see things from my point of
view I am extremely disappointed with my
life
yeah but I did you don't have to do many
more favors then oh
she's great at playing people in
troubling relationships oh Mike you're
gonna learn to appreciate the present
towards the end of the movie
[Music]
get off of there
it is raining so hard hello hello
[Music]
whoa
oh cool
[Music]
it's such a nerd
[Music]
oh no
he'll be fine oh
wow I feel great
[Music]
don't use Excalibur
[Music]
you have an understanding testicleable
this is not a bad uh impromptu
lightsaber fight they're having
oh
my God
[Music]
we're looking at your basic
spirit guide Transformation Magic the
hero uh is transformed by his spirit
guide to set him on A New Path
which is what what do I look like your
spirit guide
you know what to do abandon your family
go back to high school I'm going back to
high school man net this is my chance
this is my chance to have my life over
but to do it right it's much
bigger
it's about you oh yeah this is
this is cool this is hip
to the picture of Kevin Federline
wearing the exact same thing
as little as possible hey watch where
you're going to a bag Stan
he's gonna be an important character I'm
Jane Masterson principal here at Hayden
High hi
she looks very familiar she's not from
the office is she I think her hands just
made a baby
excuse my dad he's not used to talking
to attractive women
well thank you for that uh flattering
yet totally inappropriate comment
it's about to say
I'm single
and I'm very rich okay
did you bring your transcripts oh yeah I
think Hayden would be lucky to have you
welcome thank you
your hair is pretty thank you
would the lady mind if I smelled it oh
my God I don't date my students parents
okay well maybe I should tell you that I
never don't not date the principal of my
child
[Laughter]
and the least I can do is make sure that
my fake son doesn't look look like a
total douche
look like a douche douche
he's hurt as good background say it
I would not drive that kind of car to
high school where the hell are you
do you take any of this seriously I'm
a lot closer to them than you think
let's reschedule I hope she's not
attracted to him
[Music]
kid oh my God he's still here we're
looking for a point guard oh yeah
let's come to tryouts okay
all right I'm done talking yeah
you're still gonna turn into Matthew
Perry in a few years I need you to get
in trouble just enough trouble so that
the principal needs to meet with your
father
yeah okay well we'll see uh can I get a
little help in here Alex
oh he's bullied uh your uncle Ned's kid
I just started here just just
yeah just go for it
I guess they're really bond with him
no no she's the uh she's the head
cheerleader
I should never go out when I first met
your mother I was so nervous I met my
mother
What You My Mother yeah you just said
the first time I Met Your Mother yeah oh
that's weird is your mom hot dude
[Laughter]
yesterday shoved me in the washing
machine in my own house what was that
jerk doing at your house like it's
Maggie's boyfriend
oh my goodness
oh my goodness this just keeps getting
worse and worse I'm very disappointed in
your sister
I wanted you in the cafeteria I would
have taped you to a lunch lady you don't
talk to him that way
what are you gonna do oh my God I'm so
invested in this right now
I'm gonna call your father
heads up
nicely done Sigourney Weaver Alien
Resurrection
too easy to say stand praise in the week
simply because he's a
[Music]
h
see according to Leading psychiatrists
stands a bully for one of three reasons
one
oh my God he's so cool with that ball
Stan's brain is
underdeveloped
therefore Stan is unable to use
self-control and the third reason
Stan has a small wiener oh [ __ ]
that would hurt today in the 30s age
group
[Music]
damn way to show him up what did you
learn at school today that I'm a bad dad
what are you talking about I thought it
was going great it was going fantastic
for me
and then and and then what
that is a really disgusting sandwich man
but I think I was wrong about my spirit
path it's not about basketball
it's about helping Alex and Maggie
there we go
what was that
three-pointer
oh my God he's actually good at
basketball
what's he doing a little pressure
you're your Father's son I'm gonna get
you on the team
that's it that'll that'll solve
everything
what really matters is that you're there
for your children
Michael yeah exactly Mike I've never
heard of the guy ow
hey Mom this is Mark Uncle Ned's bastard
wow
you look just like my husband
weird did you see that I did I did
you're gonna go to jail lady I mean I
know that you need to grieve a
relationship it's only natural okay
you wait here
you need to hook up with someone new
oh no
you look turd mother who is still
married by the way is planning on
running around with every guy you can
get our hands on If This Were
Afghanistan she'd be dragged through the
streets by goats with her hands cut off
I'm just saying Naomi Naomi I don't care
uh
huh they're the same person
be continuing our discussion on human
sexuality and as we discuss the official
school policy is abstinence now that
is very sensible I'm glad that someone
here has their heads screwed on straight
[Laughter]
hair you for safe sex now so please take
one and pass it down
you serious did I do that it's called
making love isn't it maybe I'm
old-fashioned but I I think that means
that you do it with someone you love
and preferably when you're married
turn it into
a baby
because that's what love is it's the
first moment when you hold your baby
girl
and you didn't know that anything could
be so small oh no is he gonna cry
delicate and and you feel that tiny
heartbeat
and you know that you couldn't love
anything more in the whole world
is she attracted to him well I'm so
worried about what's gonna happen
this is like a reverse situation of big
and Back to the Future
[Music]
oh god dude
I'm gonna go to jail again
hey you can go to the principal's office
now
talking
you think that's going to work I think
it's just mine
it's gonna work
oh wow yeah
obviously I still have a lot to do
he's doing a phenomenal job to put a
pond in over here and a flagstone patio
there with sod in between then to have
twinkling lights above the whole thing
so that every night is a starry one it's
gonna be amazing scar score
don't call her score
I realized that whole lady Cougar
Hunting the mothers I'd like to you know
whatever it's called MILF thinking more
along the lines of business experience
college application but if you want to
go there that's okay so I'll just get
you a shovel then yeah okay time to
seduce make things a real
real unclear area where we are the age
appropriateness
oh my God he's even rekindling his love
[Music]
wow that's hyper aggressive but she is
an unusually hot principal what happened
at the tryout tryouts it was good Mark
Mark had a great tryout he played great
and so did I made the team
so good I'm so proud
[Laughter]
Zac Efron is so funny
it's not fair again you look like him
and you're that funny it's not fair what
do you think
it's amazing when people see this when
people see how talented you are you
could be designing Gardens all over the
city I have a date tonight I have to go
you have a date
it's ridiculous because
I'm a terrible dancer so I'm an amazing
dancer what
stop talking
you just look like you can move
um
foreign
[Music]
that was a very hot dance when you were
one teach it to me I can't try me
no this is so bad this is so confusing
what does it say about her if she hooks
up with him
you stand here
okay like that I'll stand here no
you're picking that up pretty quickly
mention your husband do you think you
guys are ever going to get back together
um no
why are you so sure
maybe there's something he could do to
fix things
[Laughter]
[Music]
mom yeah
she's nervous it's creepy right a little
bit
she's so old it's like
[Laughter]
mind him that he needs to be there on
the 27th
okay thank you
no you gotta win her back
or be 17 and sleep around High School
which would then be creepy in context
because you're not actually a 17 year
old I used to date the most beautiful
girl in school and I let her slip
through my fingers but I'm not gonna let
that happen to you
you're right you're absolutely right I'm
just gonna walk up to her and then
respect yeah yeah
tomorrow at school
[Laughter]
the mentality goes right Maggie's not
here but um I am and I'm really really
glad you came
it's my birthday I didn't get you a
present I'm sorry I'll just have to
unwrap you hey hey
I was kicked off the cheerleading squad
for being too flexible okay okay sit
down
just sit down
those don't respect yourselves then how
do you expect anyone else to respect you
right don't respect me no don't respect
me you don't even have to remember my
name oh my God
I'm just I just I just want to tell you
that you look like my dog
what did you just say she's a sweetheart
she died
so I look like you're a dead dog
don't worry about it really people care
Alex yeah oh my God you know my name
you're on fire really literally how'd
this happen literally on fire oh no okay
I'm gonna get out of here
don't let anyone record you Stan got on
the management track at Home Depot oh
great and I'm going to Westward
Community College to be closer to him
he's my forever he's gonna cheat on you
in this movie You Think I'm Gonna Let
You mortgage your future you're gonna
let you throw away all your hard work I
forbid you to see him anymore oh okay
who the hell do you think you are my
father
hey how'd it go fantastic
you're botching this
what are you doing let's
oh no oh no he's falling apart he's
getting too mad this is actually really
well done man
damn he's so good
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
so happy for him
[Applause]
oh
my God she's hugging him oh my God it's
working I'll buy every student a laptop
you would deny the children of laptops
Miss Masterson the children okay oh my
God that's awful but this is not a date
no in no way a day and if I do this you
will stop the inappropriate behavior and
gifts and we're just going to drive to
this restaurant we're not going to fly
there in the space shuttle
I don't want this movie to end get to
another chance how how are you gonna do
that
Victory board in my house
smart call
Stand double to be what did he do he
took me behind the quad and we can't
hear this you didn't
[Music]
why
that's why you dumped me
when you're young Everything feels like
the end of the world
it's not
okay
beginning
you're gonna meet a boy
who treats you the way that you deserve
to be treated
do not turn your attention to him
I know so I don't know what happened
right now
okay
I was looking for you I wanted to invite
you to my party I don't know if you want
to come tonight yeah I would love to yes
thank you that's very exciting
oh this is bad let's reverse Back to the
Future
foreign
just trying to impress you okay and the
kind of guy who spends 10 grand on
Gandalf degrees Quarter Staff from The
Two Towers
yes that does make you a dork
especially since Gandalf the Gray was
only in Fellowship
he returns in two towers as Gandalf
[Music]
foreign I
[Music]
am literally crying
I'm just so freaking funny
oh boy I've haven't cried from laughter
in a long time
Jesus Christ you can have the nun
and put out anyway you know on second
thought
[Music]
because I know how to throw a punch oh
my God is he gonna Wake Up Older I was
17.
I was back in high school it's all the
way back to the future I know why you
didn't want me to be
no no no no I'm hungry lioness and
you're a baby gazelle
Maggie I'm not the person I'm not the
person just say you're gay man what are
you saying
are you confused
I'm very confused yeah
[Laughter]
I'm not gay
I'm in love Maggie I'm I'm in love you
tell your girlfriend she
put close eye on you
wow okay blast glass
ES
oh my God it's happening hi
we're great she's cute come on I'll show
you where just walk upstairs
ah
everybody
this party is over
oh he's gonna have his kiss
mom this has been a really tough time
and
and you really feel like part of the
family oh no
no
don't
[Music]
no no if you want to listen to me I am
the father of your children Scott let me
explain don't don't call me that you are
a weirdo little man child
can't explain this you are a pervert
no no it's all falling apart All Is Lost
[Laughter]
I'm sure now you can see why I don't
date my students parents
oh
oh Mike Mark you have done
effed up I had no idea that it was gonna
get so out of control
okay now I'm sorry I guess I deserve
that
second one was on call for I'm sorry are
you okay
I'm really sorry man
that looks painful no maybe they don't
need me anymore but I need them
you're not to be a buzz kill but um
you're due in court in
22 minutes I have to stop this to the
netmobile
[Laughter]
I've got a letter here
from Mike O'Donnell he's the husband in
this case no I'm sorry Mike but we're in
the middle of Runner if it's okay I'd
like to hear the letter please it's
smart that they made her recognize him
to look like her husband
I want to remind you of September 7th
1988. you were wearing a Guns and Roses
t-shirt I remember thinking that I had
to have you or I'd Die
then you whispered that you loved me
at the homecoming dance
and I blamed you for my failures
and I know that you think you have to do
this today
I don't want you to
damn heck everyone's so good in this
movie
if I love you
I should let you move on
no kiss that 17 year old boy you know he
was telling the truth
[Music]
you'd know it she knows
[Music]
that is so sweet
[ __ ] oh boy it has an emotional thing to
do
that's clever
oh
this movie
he is really good at basketball
got a little inside info for you Scout
from Ohio State is back oh my God
playing college ball next year huh
that's the plan coach
yeah the picture time
this guy was in this exact position 20
years ago I understand but I am
I am the prince of
the principal and I cannot be seen with
my students parents how can you be seen
with me when I'm wearing
a cloak of invisibility
[Laughter]
you can plunder my dungeon anytime
I'll bring my longbow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this movie's so touching
[Applause]
[Music]
I've really been trying not to cry
this is soaked
[Music]
it's a classic transformation story
guy
make the same Choice again it's your
turn now
[Applause]
[Music]
love it if you were to do it all over
again he would this is the best movie
I've seen all year
he's Matthew Perry
you didn't have to come after me again
yes I did because I love you
you're the best decision I ever made I
just forgot
look I I know that I've been in a bad
mood for the last
20 years
I thought I wanted a second chance at
life but now I know I just want a second
chance with you
yeah
yeah
I missed you
does he realize he's turned back
ah this is a touching ass film this was
a lot easier before
checking me out I want Taco Bell
pick up all my stuff and I wanted to
give you a key back and say thanks it
was hey whoa no no wasn't expecting to
see you there principal Masterson you
look very
pretty health is yours so I guess I'll
be seeing you at work boss oh yes coach
O'Donnell and um we are very happy to oh
I was thinking over the coach's job yeah
a little something for your first day at
your new job don't think about how much
it cost
it's got me a whistle
don't blow it
[Laughter]
YouTube
love you
I said it back
best movie of the year or whatever that
was came out 2009.
ah I love the hell out of that film that
was
that was so good
I was so good
Jesus Christ
so blown away right now
I I I got moved to tears out of turning
down the brightness of this TV I got
moved to tears
from
just how touching and sweet it was then
I got I I I don't remember the last time
I mean in real I remember the last time
in real life
I don't remember the last time on the
camera pointed at me that I I cried out
of laughter that that [ __ ] was so funny
like it was just so good freaking Zac
Efron you know I I don't think I ever
saw an actual Zac Efron movie until
neighbors you know like I had that kind
of I remember watching uh The Dark
Knight when it came out and in the
theater
like here is my association with Zac
Efron he was like he was that kid from
High School Musical and I've never to
this day seen High School Musical
and so when The Dark Knight was playing
they played a trailer for The
theatrically released High School
Musical 3 and everyone in the theater
like I didn't boo because I didn't I
don't know I had no investment into the
hatred for it or whatever but everyone
started booing
and so that was my association with what
to think of Zac Efron at like 18 years
old that's is that kid is that kid so I
think that's partly why I didn't see
this movie because I just kind of had
that like it's probably just some like
kids movie or some [ __ ] and so the first
movie I ever saw of him was um
uh neighbors and I thought he was
hysterical in that film
and it did have that feeling of man he's
one of those like athletic ass like a
Chris Hemsworth like you're you're so
charming and athletic and you're all so
funny like he's just the whole package
son of a [ __ ]
it's like leave some for the rest of us
but he didn't hear and watching him at
uh uh even before then you know when
he's still playing like you know real
kids like high schoolers
I thought he was excellent he he
he hit just that right pitch perfect
note
and you know like I love that you you do
get to see his display of like
athleticism especially with a basketball
that's right in that High School Musical
trailer that we're playing it's
basketball a big part of that movie I've
never seen any of it so I don't know so
he strikes me as the kind of guy who'd
just be naturally great at basketball I
mean shows in this movie but he it
struck that right pitch of being that he
did everything like him and Matthew
Perry actually complimented each other
so well it felt like a full-on character
like he wasn't just playing the comedy
if that makes sense he was actually
being the character he was being the the
older might keep like he had to play
someone in the high school later I know
he probably wasn't in high school people
usually play older to younger people are
usually older than they play younger and
he had to play like the actual adult
version of Mike internally who wants to
be young and I thought it might have
been one of those movies going in where
it's just about reliving The Glory Days
and just recapturing that magic of what
it was like to be popular in high school
again and then eventually go down the
predictable path of appreciating what
you actually have but it took such a
different direction than what I was
expecting like it full on became you
know reversed Back to the Future where
instead of Marty McFly helping out you
know his dad and then the mom falling in
love with him like the opposite turn of
it's like the daughter's falling falling
for him and and you know you've seen the
movie so yeah as if it's going I was so
surprised by the different path it was
taking and I love how they kept the fact
that he was an adult like he wasn't
hooking up up with anyone he wasn't he
didn't even seem tempted to and those
fatherly qualities like the Mike
O'Donnell adult father the Matthew Perry
within him would would come out in
conversation but it wasn't like a Beat
to Death kind of joke it wasn't like a
one note joke they kept doing
it felt very human he felt like a real
person as opposed to Zac Efron just
doing the comedy bits of there's an
older man inside of me like that's what
I'm really playing he he played like the
confidence the dumbfounded part the
fatherly quality like he did it it was
so natural and unbelievable and felt
lived in and that's such a big part of
what made the comedy sing so strongly
like even his relationship with uh
what's his name Thomas Lennon should I
pull up the IMDb in case I forgot her
name for a situation like this yeah
Thomas Lennon yeah
hilarious actor by the way Thomas Lennon
uh like even that relationship between
him and Thomas London like you see
Matthew Perry and him in the beginning
and like yeah the same age okay it makes
sense and then it didn't feel like a
younger guy interacting with an older
actor you could still feel that
friendship and camaraderie like they
even had great chemistry together in the
Zac Efron form
and Thomas London's net gold like while
I think Thomas London is a hilarious guy
he's he is a hilarious guy has a lot of
Versatility
at first his character I thought was uh
he might be a little bit annoying like
he's not that funny and this this nerd
thing is is a little uh
it's it seems like
sketch writing right
but as even as that went along it became
like that was my breaking point when the
principle was speaking to happen to each
other because it was already like so
funny and then it just got so hiding in
that moment and such a such a great way
of doing the as opposed to just
discovering that they're both nerds the
reveal of that was hilariously done it I
admire the cleverness of how they
captured it and and uh and even his
character I was so endeared and so
connected to his character and their
friendship and then even by the end when
he says love you and then Matthew Perry
finally actually says it back you're
like ah yeah this is great this is
hilarious this is so it's so sweet and
they the the connections all around
because it's a family it's it is kind of
like Back to the Future it's weirdly a
family movie at the end of the day
you know like the friendship that he
forms with his son Alex and helping him
out through the basketball I do like
that Alex did get a chance like by the
time he actually made the battle it's
like oh my God I'm cheering for this guy
I'm really rooted for Alex too
I think they did all the Beats they
landed at I think that's what what
impressed me the most about this comedy
they landed at all the Beats you'd
expect them to land at
but you know you've always heard that
phrase right of it's not about the
ending it's about the destinations about
the journey and I think that's what this
movie excelled at was yeah the
destination of all these things is where
you like from the beginning of this
movie where you'd sort of expected to
land
but the way they got there was done in
ways that were unexpected to me and ways
that kind of you know had moments Rose
kind of on edge because when they are
doing the the daughters uh you know when
uh oh my God hold on there's a reason I
got IMDb up here I'm so bad remembering
it uh teen Scarlet no no no no Scarlet
teen is younger Scarlet what the hell is
that Maggie uh when you have Maggie and
and and uh mark
and the sexual tension happening on her
and
man that was just putting me over the
edge and even like I liked how they had
fun like sometimes they the the the
phrase that comes to mind is like it
feels like sometimes we're playing with
fire because
even when Leslie Mann is you know
clearly drawn to Zac Efron in this film
it creates that interesting play with
the audience of
okay we know what's going on but from
from the observational standpoint
they're like this could be like a really
icky situation because she doesn't know
that he's really like maybe something
inside but she doesn't really know and
and she doesn't know that that's really
her husband she thinks it's a 17 year
old kid so she starts hooking up with it
like that could be a really like icky
thing
and but you also like kind of want them
to have that chemistry because you know
the reality of the situation and you
know what what Mark is aiming for in
this moment or or Mike is aiming for uh
to win her back man Zac and fern is so
good in this film he is so goddamn good
you know what you you know what they're
aiming for so playing with that fire I
thought made for a really fun Dynamic
like Leslie man's always great you know
Judd Apatow's wife she's more than just
shut up she's a wonderful comedic
actress wonderful actors and uh I I
thought like her and Zac Efron's
chemistry everyone's chemistry in this
film was it was just High Praise I gotta
confirm the principle
because wasn't she the uh like the the
one who was like the boss of Michael
Scott in the office Jan was her name Jan
not Jane Jan Jan yes that was her took
me it took me a second to recognize
uh she was hilarious she she didn't
really make me laugh and like she was a
good thing for Michael Scott to play off
of but I didn't really consider her
funny in that show but she was really
funny here she had some really funny
stuff and I like the acknowledgment of
like because you know I kept wondering
like how far of the line would they push
some of some of the things they're gonna
do in this film
you know would it go like super edgy
uncomfortable because they always Teeter
right on the on the right line they knew
to Teeter on the right line but never
cross it never have like Zac Efron
hooking up with anyone and they use that
to their advantage like at the bowling
alley when they all are uh coming on a
Zac Efron so strong and he sits them
down and talk to them about respecting
themselves I thought was so good good
they registering like surprising tension
out of moments you wouldn't expect it
was more than just
because you know I I expected a laugh I
I think what I was sort of my my cynical
mind before going was just expecting you
know certain hijinks I guess like every
scene is gonna be what's the next comedy
setup of this scene and we're gonna go
do that scene
obviously setting up like not
necessarily A Sketch but a certain kind
of bit we're gonna do and they did so
much more than that they actually did
real scene work and they did real
character development for all the
characters all around you know you did
have Maggie grown to her own and and to
have the the path for her at the end be
like yeah we'll see what the future
holds and then obviously Alex's growth
for allowing him to be a basketball
player and you know that momentary hands
off the ball to him and now it's your
time so good it's so great foreign
just kind of dazzled by this movie I'm
really uh I'm taking it back by how good
it is
and of course you know obviously Mike's
Mike's obvious Arc of learning to
appreciate today and and you know themes
of gratitude or something that can
really tug at my heart
but she like the the unexpected Romance
of certain moments like in the courtroom
when he's all I'm doing is recapping
scenes I'm not even really reviewing
this we're just recapping stuff when
he's reviewing uh when he's when he's uh
in the courtroom and he's acting like
he's reading off this letter which is
recanting a memory
and and then you find it's just like
this uh directions or something that
was
that's what I mean by how cleverly
written this is I thought it was going
to be you know like oh she recognizes
that that looks like her husband's
writing I thought it was gonna be
something something simple like that
and
they did so much more with it to allow
for a good visual storytelling and I
think this movie is so much more clever
than I was anticipating what is it on
Rotten Tomatoes I just gotta find out
the end-all be-all Rotten Tomatoes
that's the one this is the god of the
opinion you should have
56 Croc of [ __ ] this film is hilarious
and much more clever
than you'd expect I don't care that it's
a formula Lake the execution of the
formula makes it an unexpected surprise
I heavily disagree as a matter of fact
the top audience com right now says this
predictable but inventive that cannot
move will dally and super reviewer I
could not like I I could not agree more
that is the best way to describe it
predictable but inventive and it hits
all the predictable notes you had to
want it to hit by the end of the journey
but the way they get there I think makes
for a really touching endearing
experience uh and it was it was like I
thought it might be cheesy and dumb and
it got better as it went and I'm not
exactly sure when the stride really hit
because it was always like entertaining
and amusing to watch there was a certain
point where it was just like
consistently really engaging and really
funny and once it found out about really
strong flow because I feel like nowadays
if you did a movie like this it would
just be set up for a comedy scene let's
look at our uh you could you could just
imagine like four riders in a room and
they they all have their index cards and
be like oh for this this sketch we could
do this scene you know something like
Ryan Reynolds and Jason Bateman in the
change up something that just feels very
bit heavy but they let EV I think that's
the the key to this film is that they
let every comedy every comedy scene
every really funny scene you know was
still somehow imbued in the characters
and and sort of advancing the the story
and the plot of the characters that they
did such a good job at that
as opposed to just set up sketch and
then insert characters there
and another thing I thought they did
well was they they took the right time
to let certain scenes be serious instead
of having a serious scene undercutting
it with a joke they allowed like not a
lot but there were certain scenes that
they really let the drama kind of hit
you in the fields
and that makes it when it does go all
comedy work even stronger because yeah
this film I thought had a great heart
and a lot of wonder
and I loved it personally I would say
this is one of my most favorite things
I've ever been that ever done a reaction
to this [ __ ] was awesome I love the hell
out of it what do you guys think about
this film leave your thoughts down below
because damn that was uh
I feel you know what it is you know what
okay this movie came out in 2009
I'm gonna I'm just gonna do I'm gonna
give a guess here because maybe I'm just
be like okay High School Musical 3 was
the year before this came out and I
remember there was a time where hating
on Zac Efron was like the thing you just
did because he was part of High School
Musical
and unless you're one of those people
that grew up with High School Musical at
the age I was at
everyone at my age and older and maybe a
little bit younger than me was all about
like kind of hating on High School
Musical like I said I went to see the
freaking dark night and everyone booed
in the theater and
I feel like that kind of played in to
why this film probably has a bit of a
lower rating because this movie's better
than a lot of comedies that come out I I
personally think so I think it's a
really well I think it's a clever it's
it's cleverly done and I feel like I'm
like a passionate defender of this film
now uh it is it is so much better than a
lot of comedies that do come out and I
think that because of the fact that Zac
Efron uh you know was just in High
School Musical through the year before
that it was the natural thing to kind of
like shine a negative Spotlight or like
watch it through that kind of lens
instead of allowing yourself to be sort
of Charmed by the film that's what I'm
gonna blame it on I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna let anyone have their own
subjective opinion I'm gonna say you're
always being a bunch of [ __ ] because
he was in high school musical three dumb
critics
anyway
we're uh we're done now thank you thank
you for being here this was this was uh
this is one of the best things I need I
I I I loved it I really loved it thank
you guys for being here
[Music]